aluminum objects that form words shadow
words sculptures that are shaped in such
a way that their shadows create
sentences or pictures but light is
needed to reveal these hidden images
where there's light there's shadow
Belgian sculptor fraid arrogance is
interested in their interplay he beams
light unto the objects at a 45-degree
angle I want this to be a correct T it
looks like a bit little bit legatee
without exactly so when I when I could
turn it a little bit the tea will appear
when you have light and shadow there's
only one place where the shadow can be
when you have a fixed point for the
light so that's the general law of
physics and maybe you can fight with it
and but you can't you always have to to
listen that the certain point great
arrogance studied sculpture and graphic
art he's been interested in the
interplay of light and shadow since 1982
he came up with the idea for his text
installations by chance I was working
with leftovers of of metal sheets and so
on and all of a sudden I I saw the name
of my daughter who was just born her
name is Lena
hell I and II and I saw her name in the
shadow and that was a startup fraid a
deacons lives and works here in hasselt
a town near Brussels surrounded by his
works large and small this one is 20
meters long and made from acrylic resin
covered with gold here it's not the
light but the correct viewing point that
makes the invisible visible his works
have been exhibited in museums and
galleries across the world and they're
also part of large private collections
the smaller installations can fetch up
to 30 thousand euros
he often uses aluminum and copper wire
but he also employs other materials to
write his shadow messages thoughts about
his life in the world I read all the
time I always think in words so they
just pop up and afterwards it it's hard
to say hey the idea comes from one thing
is certain about the arrogance work in
the beginning is the word this time he
wants to write a short story one that
consists of just two words short and
story he's pretty much optimized his
wire bending technique which seems quite
straightforward when I bend this I bend
it like her right I have to bend it with
the first video by the beginning of a
word when they won't want to make a
short story I start with the S of short
as soon as the first word is finished he
begins looking at the message under the
light Freya Deakins is a perfectionist
he may destroy his wire objects and
start over many times before he's
satisfied with the result pray dear
deacons art is more than just sculptural
forms it's poetry thoughts conveyed in
light and shadow
you